foreign
back everybody we're continuing our
trial recap out of Illinois as defendant
Bradley yawn acted as his own defense
counsel for a second day on Wednesday
Yan faces burglary carjacking kidnapping
and sexual assault charges for a
November 2021 incident involving 77 year
old Tina Schmidt the victim ended up
dying a month after the attack but
prosecutors haven't pursued murder
charges however prosecutors do believe
that the trauma that Schmidt endured did
play a role in her death as Jan faces
life in prison he's choosing to
represent himself in court and has done
so for the past two days in the last
segment we looked at a interesting
exchange outside the presence of the
jury from Wednesday morning and that
ended in one of Yan's relatives getting
banned from the courtroom so let's take
a look at how testimony has been going
as both prosecutors and Jan himself got
a chance to address Witnesses Sergeant
Joe lohmeyer a first responder at the
scene testified about Schmidt's demeanor
following the attack and Jan did some
attacking of his own in court
she was on the floor
there was some crying but it was also I
think what I've seen in other people's
shock there was like a pain for kind of
remembering it you know and some
hesitation
and and it was kind of a little bit
disjointed as far as how the
conversation went what would you say if
I made a statement that
some of the things you have related here
today are contrary to maybe with the
person objection and proper impeachment
I'll sustain the objection you may
rephrase the question several times
throughout these witness testimonies
thus far
Witnesses have looked directly over at
State's Attorneys for guidance Mr Lowe
Meyer just did a moment ago Mr John have
you noticed either of the assistant
State's Attorneys giving an answer to
the witness I I tried
to look and catch this time but no I
have not here honor okay neither has the
court and so where the witness looks
while answering questions I cannot
control but unless the assistant States
attorneys are indicating some kind of
answer that they should be giving the
there's no reason to basically uphold
your objection
Joseph let me start with you so Mr Yan
he isn't charged with murder the
prosecution though has heavily suggested
that Schmidt died from the stress of
this encounter months later is that a
real thing medically oh yeah yeah it is
uh go back to the old analogy there's
the old poem about for the one of a nail
the Horseshoe was lost so forth and so
on and you you had this intersection of
these events that occur so the question
I think from at least a philosophical
standpoint you have to ask had she not
had this encounter that particular
evening would this precious woman still
be with us and that's a that's I think
that that can be rightly asked and
answer at this point in time of course
the court might not see it that way
certainly prosecution at this point in
time does seem like they're pursuing
that but yeah I think that it's it there
have been I've been involved in cases
where people have died as a result of a
heart attack as a result of having a
weapon placed in their face and that
person has was convicted as a result of
that I remember that very stink
well Brian we joke around about it it
doesn't look like Jan's doing a really
good job of representing himself that's
my take I mean are there advantages to
going pro se though that may help him
that we're not thinking of so as a
defense attorney we often say that all
the discovery in the world is amazing
but the best source of Discovery is your
client the difference is when you get
that information from your client you
filter it through a legal lens and there
you have the ability to make the
objections you have the ability to
cross-examine to bring in evidence
because you know how that comes in it's
as I tell my clients it's one thing to
know what happened it's another thing to
be able to prove it and so he knows what
happened more so than anyone else
especially in a case with a victim he's
not being charged with murder but died
so they're not going to have their star
witness he could be the star witness
himself but he just doesn't know how to
move on the court of law properly that's
a good point so with the proper you know
legal education maybe he would have been
a formidable
um you know enemy to the prosecution or
the middle of a foe if he knew the right
questions to ask because he knows the
story better than others that's a good
point well I'll tell you what coming up
whether you're a multi-million dollar
celebrity or just a regular Joe it is a
good idea to have a will and we have an
update for you on which will governs the
late Aretha Franklin's estate after
multiple were found scribbled on pieces
of paper
[Music]
and we end Today's Show with an update
for you and also a reminder and that is
that is always a good idea to have a
written will a Michigan jury decided
that a handwritten note found under a
couch cushion is the true will of the
late Soul Superstar Aretha Franklin the
will was written in 2014 more recently
than another one being considered which
was in written in 2010. Franklin known
as the queen of Seoul died in 2018 from
pancreatic cancer at the age of 76. her
niece found three handwritten Wills in
Franklin's home after her death the
argument over which will was valid has
divided Franklin's Sons her youngest son
who goes by Kell is named as executor in
the most recent well that will also
states that Cal and Franklin's
grandchildren are entitled to her home
in Bloomfield Hills Michigan now both
versions of the will allow her four Sons
to benefit from music royalties and
copyrights but let's talk about this so
Jose of the will that was not notarized
and that was found under the couch was
the will that was found to be valid
what's your reaction when you heard that
well uh my friends that are question
document examiners right now are
probably thrilled about this because
this is going to be a perfect case for
them to teach when it comes to forensic
document examination uh it's fascinating
to me that someone at this level and I
have the ultimate respect for her uh
would you know leave this I don't know
this Fortune her life I mean her Legacy
unguarded uh you know and not have
something officially filed I am uh I
don't know gobsmacked over the fact that
they went with the one that was not
notarized that's pretty fascinating to
me yeah it was the later one you know
all you need to sign dated and true
intention uh it's the holographic Wills
in Michigan I mean Brian one of the
arguments during trial was that it
didn't it didn't matter where the well
was found the will is it will is that
true that's true especially you already
articulated the requirements from
Michigan Michigan is one of 26 states in
the U.S New York is not one of them that
allows for these hand Wren or
holographic Wills now in the closing
Arguments for both Cal and Edward
Franklin the opening statement was out
of the first line of that 2014 Will
wheretha Franklin says this is my will
and where the heart of the argument
comes down to what is her intent yes
Joseph's got Morgan is right it's
notarized that makes sense why is it not
that one but when she starts off with
this is my will that clearly was enough
for the jury who decided this case in
less than an hour but the battle is
still not done we just know which will
is going to be followed now the question
is the details I think both sides have
to file motions to see who's going to be
the executor how's it all work out yeah
it's an interesting case but the end of
the day maybe you have a written will
with Witnesses and follow the
requirements maybe it would make things
easier